I want to thank everybody for the all
you've taught me and what I've learned
in particular is how difficult some of
these issues are and how in spite of
having a bunch of really smart and
well-intentioned people around the room
there's still tremendous possibilities
for miscommunication where you can get
these hidden pitfalls where you can fall
in a hole
you don't realize till you're halfway
through the talking you realize some of
these jumping up and down and what's
that about and then so you echoing what
Sean just said or not echoing it but
recasting it I think Sean was
acknowledging the distinction between
the manifest and the scientific image
and the difficult task of putting them
into registration and what we've heard
is that there are several terms that
don't go nicely at all one of them is
design we had an interesting debate of
that one of them is free will itself one
of them is emergence and the other one
is rationality well there's four
Biggie's right there and I'm going to
add a fifth one which is imaginary
because it's an old thought experiment
which I think clarifies this we we go to
some distant archipelago and we find
people that speak English except for one
thing where we talk about being tired
bushed exhausted they talk about all the
fatigues they have oh I got so many
fatigues in my body now more fatigues in
my legs and in my arms and that's just
that that's their conceptual scheme
that's where they talk and we show up
and they say all right mr. mr. scientist
mrs. scientist tell us what fatigues are
now what do we do do we say there aren't
any fatigues and they say there are any
fatigues run around the block you'll
know fatigues I can feel them so that's
not a very profitable pursuit if we say
well I'll tell you what fatigues are and
then we take on the bizarre task of
trying to come up with a identification
of fatigues with very insufficient
necessary sufficient
we've got a lot of things about blood
sugar and lactic acid as well that's not
know what we want to do we say look
turns out your term doesn't carve nature
at the joints really we'll teach you
this other stuff instead and we'll just
sort of show you how you can go back and
forth between them and we're going to
define fatigues and we're not going to
eliminate fatigues you want to go talk
about fatigue the way we talk about
sunsets flying now I think that the
moral of that story applies for all of
these terms so what do I think let's
take the one that matters to me the most
here first of all I would say emergence
for me I just assumed getting rid of the
term because I think that there's so
much baloney that's been said about
emergence it's it's it's got more than
barnacles on it
I don't mind barnacles all that other
stuff I don't free will is in a very
delicate position
because if you've just banished it you
create a vacuum of social vacuum which
is really scary you've got all these
people out there saying soil shows we
don't have free will and therefore
nobody is ever responsible and and
therefore well nobody nobody nobody is
thinking through the implications of
that if you doubt that well one person
has thought through the implications and
that's Bruce Waller in the book that
I've sent you all a review of and you
read that you think whether you really
like the direction that that's going so
when I said that these issues are
political part of the political problem
I think is that we do have to talk to
the to the non-scientific
non-naturalistic world about these
things and
terms that we can agree on how best to
use may nevertheless backfire in our
faces very badly
you